皆さん、モテたいですよね！
モテる上で何が一番大切か
まぁ、色んな要素があると思うんですけども
まぁ・・・
これはでも、どうしようもない
まぁ、何とかできるけどどうしようもない部分として
他には、髪型
なんか、筋肉つけたり
体を細くしたり、服とか
色んな要素があって、人はモテるモテない、色々あると思うんですけども
忘れてはいけない大切な要素が一つあるんです
それは何か！
そう
人というものは表情一つで
もう、モテるモテない大きく変わってくると思うんですよ
例えばですよ
超美人の人がずっと
ずっとこういう顔してたら嫌でしょ
美人の人がずっとこういう顔してたら嫌だと思うんですよ
逆にですよ、逆にすげぇブサイクな
すげぇブサイクな人が、仮に居たとしても
その人がすごい優しい顔で微笑んでくれたり
すごい見るだけでドキッとするような顔でこう、ニコってしてくれたら
んん・・・
まぁとりあえず何が言いたいかというと表情ってすごい大切なんですよ
で、表情をつくる上で表情筋いうこの
構成する顔上の周りの筋肉があるんですけども
この筋肉を鍛えることがかなりモテるためには大事なのかなと思いまして
今回こちら買ってみました。はい！ブル子
リフトアップトレーナーブルブル
何かこう、えぇ？
ブルブル震えてなんかねこう、筋肉を鍛えれるんですよ。何？
ほっぺたと、口角を刺激して、こうなんか筋肉をほぐしてくれるのかな？
一日三回三セットで表情が変わってくるらしいです
何か僕昔テレビで見たことあるんですけども、表情筋ってホントに大切らしくて
こう、俺達がジジィバ・・・あっ
俺達がおじいちゃんおばあばん・・・
フフッｗダメだ直んねぇｗｗ
俺達がおじいちゃんおばあちゃんになっていくと
顔の表情の筋肉がどうしてもたるんでくるんですよ
それでなんかこう老けて見えたり、タルーンと見えておじいちゃんに見えたりするんで
顔の表情筋をしっかり維持すれば、若く見えるらしいです！
やりましょう！
結構いいこと言ってると思うんですよね
いやぁ、俺ももうすぐアラサーだからさ、なるべく若くいたい訳よ
これですね
これを？
唇でこわえうお（くわえると）
ふん（うん）
この振動で表情筋を鍛える・ほぐすという訳か
え？これホントにこんなので強く〒※§◯・・・ホントにこれで表情筋が強くなる△％◯＃×・・・微妙なんですけど
え、でもすげぇな電池も使わずにこれができるってなかなかいいんじゃないですかね
あぁ、何かすごい、ホントだ、なんか
顔の筋肉が、顔の筋肉がなんかかゆい
なんだこれ×２
表情筋が強くなってるってことか
わい、あ゛ぁぁ！！
何か使ってみて思ったんですけど
効果そこそこありそうな気がしますねぇ
で、これ一日三回三セットって書いてあるので
ちょっと面倒臭いと
一日三回三セットやるのも面倒臭いと思ったんで、
これ三つ買って、三つ一気に口につければ
一日三回三セット分の三回が無くなって、一日三セットで済むんじゃないかという
口のサイズ的にも多分三つぐらいが限界だと思うので、この三つを一気に付けて、三セットやれば
誰でも！速攻で！モテる！いい表情を！つくれるんだと思います
とりあえず一回二つでやってみましょう
二つならイケるでしょ
ばぁ！！
ん、ん、ん、ん、ん、ん、ん、んんんんん
おぎゃぁぁぁぁあああ！！
無理！！
ちょっとこれやって思ったんですけども、結構顔の筋肉には来るんで
これはもう表情筋絶対鍛えれますわ
え？待って血出てねぇ？
は？待て表情筋どころの騒ぎじゃねぇわ
うわ！めっちゃ血出てきた！
なんかめっちゃ血出てきたんですけど
これをやり続ければ最強の表情筋が付くと思うので、僕ちょっともうちょっと頑張ってみます
（こうしてはじめは、）
（表情筋を鍛えるために）
（来る日も来る日も、唇に唇を重ね）
（表情筋のトレーニングをし続けた）
シルク）唇のこれ
取れなくなっちゃったｗ
♪〜（ED)
（ED）ﾃﾃﾞﾃﾞﾃﾞ！